today we are playing bed wars with 100
players and the team you're gonna want
to keep an eye on is white team they
have carl chris and technoblade this
youtuber right here who literally won
1400 games at bed wars in a row and i'm
gonna go ahead and start it now oh wow
what whoa we're gonna win begin fighting
gentlemen you guys have technoblade on
your team and carl technoblade is o.p
either you sacrifice technoblade or i
put a ten thousand dollar bounty on your
team's head whoa
what the heck is techno worth the 10k
bounty bounty bounty yeah bounty baby
guys purple team is on the way look out
purple is attacking white purple is
attacking white see oh techno's on the
front lines i'm going for it i'm gonna
knock down as many guys as i can oh
tango's going in hot dakdo doesn't care
oh my gosh he just killed like oh my
goodness techno went down but he took
like eight people down with him i
knocked down like three guys and don't
worry in bed wars when you die you
respawn at your bed but if someone
destroys your bed you no longer respawn
that's why the entire team is protecting
the bed techno i'd never sell you out
unless it was a 20k bounty thank you
that means a lot i need help please
where where are you guys my team
abandoned me ah where are you guys at
i'm fighting green by myself so i don't
know how to speed bridge i don't know
how to build anything actually i've
never played this before i'm not good
okay i'm gonna go check it on purple
because they're fronting and assault oh
you're bad about them destroyed your bed
no oh oh they destroyed your bed
no way you're kidding where my bed were
sweat set i am a sky blocked sweat good
enough i'll take it guys replace the
blocks replace the battery oh green
team's also coming green's coming this
is not good can we still take the bounty
no not that i would oh purple team has a
path right to us oh purple's here
purple's here green's going above us
yeah boom down get the ball easy
get the most you better run purple
team's about to be eliminated white team
they're getting hit from all sides what
up green team hello what up whatever
team wins everyone on the team gets a
thousand dollars oh
let's go
but on top of that if you destroy white
team's bed because they have technoblade
you get 10 grand there's something to
kill him but it's kind of hard you know
true he is technoblade oh more purple
coming in one guy who wears siege on all
sides
i killed another oh we're popping off i
am over top of purple right now i'm on
the top of their base
ow they know me
he ate a gap oh no what the hawk man i'm
proud of you white team you guys are
doing good so far oh yeah we're really
good purple's coming purple's coming
they're making a push three of them oh
wait wait what's that red guy he came
out of nowhere oh look at this sneak
attack oh blue guy blue guy blue got
they're all cross teaming they're all
cross teaming right now oh we got the
glass it's immune to tnt let's go big
brains even though it's 50 versus 10 you
have techno i'm going for it i'm not
gonna make it but i'm going for it i'm
going for green
i actually got green suck it nerds it
was so worth it see you suckers
war is breaking out over here let's go
see what red's talking about what's up
mr b what up everybody i got your signed
shirt on my wall right now on your ball
wall
oh yellow's bombarding you i'm gonna go
over to red techno i'm coming watch out
techno's covering it hot can the ten of
you stop one techno blade oh i'm so dead
i'm so dead
can one of you stop a techno the red
team is such a good defense you guys
survived
bless you thank you carl there's a dude
is that guy on our team no oh he's grey
it's so hard to tell if gray's white
what oh another disadvantage for us oh
there's an orange guy at her bed he's
distracting us he's distracting us it's
so hard to tell who's gray and who's
white red guy above us oh they're
dropping tnt good thing we got glass
oh he's breaking in he's breaking in oh
no
uh did he get it did he get it oh a bed
was broken gray's bed was broken green
team what happened when did you guys get
eliminated wait technoblade just came to
your island and just murdered you all
pretty much an orange we were we were
pressured the entire time play a clip of
what their base looked like literally 10
minutes ago and now compared to this you
guys got pillaged techno techno i have a
really important job for you yes okay
stay right here and protect me while i
pee go go go all right can i at least
have your bow
here i'll throw you his boat
there you go i got killed for it
i'm back you guys are very special to me
because blue is my favorite color gosh
darn it you better get the victory
look me in the eyes and tell me you will
slaughter technoblade
now get out there and go destroy their
bed for 10 grand
all right i just gassed up blue team
they're about to go to war wait
someone's breaking the glass
someone's in we're gone oh oh my god
what the heck was that techno he just
i don't know where he came from techno
education fly congratulations on
destroying their beds so you just won
ten thousand dollars
that's great subscribe to mr beast boys
techno tell it to me straight man are we
still winning this uh depending on how
hard we get targeted honestly
i got killed that's a bad player to lose
all right i'm going for diamonds
oh no
i'm gonna die wait where are you give
him bow support nope god all right it's
the six of us left chris you died i did
die well hey now that you guys died you
can help me commentate i've been all
alone this whole time we got five guys
left it's not looking great for us i'm
not gonna lie yo chris
i'm becoming a right side jimmy you know
what that means uh oh text messages i am
officially removing all beds oh
if you die now you don't respond oh
they're breaking all beds this is our
moment this is our moment it's time to
camp harder than ever before because
we're the second lowest player team
right now sorry blue team but i wanted
to do it myself no goodbye your bet is
gone sorry for shooting you off to kill
you that's okay because i have a little
bit of payback now
i'm sorry blue team no one has beds but
you are tied for the most amount of
players alive play your cards right you
could each win a thousand dollars every
kill is final now we're up against teams
twice our size stay together right side
jimmy's coming out no i don't like right
side jimmy your team has one minute to
kill someone or your whole
team loses wait how are we even going to
get to someone in one minute last time
they did this they couldn't really do
they just want people fighting i really
think they're lying uh-uh we're not
lying go kill people or you're banned
yeah you think we're lying go hey
there's a blue guy right here by himself
guys why are you not going after him
blue guy is slow shoot the blue guy he's
slow oh blue guy super low and red guy's
shooting them all yeah yes carl's team's
going after him get him get him get him
i'm fireballing him i'm fireballing him
he's down he's doing oh no carl's team
got him yes white got the kill oh
they're closing in on you oh this is the
end of purple i'm sorry it was nice i'm
sorry okay right gotta kill oh they're
starting the world border this is gonna
suck so techno i wanted to join to ask
you a question yeah how did you get so
good at this at the the art of
destroying beds actually went out right
right when i graduated high school i was
like hey what if i played bedwars for
like eight hours a day for like two
months is that all it takes let's go out
with the bang gray okay
this is your screen time
make it last five remaining grade
players are going on an all-out assault
will they wipe out the blue team dude
this is so epic to watch play epic music
they're storming
oh no no no no no no you're you're too
deep now to back out it's now we're
never a great team
oh they got one
oh my god are you guys gonna make it
away you two were the only ones to make
out alive i missed my fallen soldiers oh
there's the border it showed up
look at it in all of its borderly
goodness blue and red are starting to
have a fight oh god orange is the best
orange is taking above holy cow they're
getting the high ground they have like a
perfect sight line on us retreat retreat
this place sucks oh we might be dead
boys are you willing to team with blue
yes i'm not enforcing it you guys can
turn on each other whenever
oh the border is like right there we got
to go faster oh my gosh look at the
border look at the border we gotta go oh
lord oh blue versus red it's happening
now great team with blue oh techno your
back's against the wall they're getting
rained down this is like an epic war
movie looking white looking white gapple
gaffle up gamble up fellas techno 10
million people are watching i want to
see you go berserk oh you're out of the
zone oh i'm about to die to the border
anyways go go go go go go go go go go go
go go off kill i want to see you murder
red team's retreating get to a corner
orange is just waiting this out just
shooting arrows down you guys should go
down and fight we're working our way
there i want some fighting i want war
i'm going in with tnt
yes i got a guy with the tnt
nope oh i'm dead
and white is gone we did well we did
well oh my god great team how are you
guys still alive i don't know you've
been through a lot you stormed flew you
win against everyone here just the two
of you and you've made it this far don't
let it in now oh orange is going for it
great he is so dead
i'm so sorry though 3v5 go red holy cow
5v3 it's red versus orange what will
they do it should be a very
straightforward match 5v2 oh dear evans
1v5 oh my gosh it will be a 1v5 we will
see what happens
oh my god congratulations on the dove
you guys just won your very first mr
views challenge what's going through
your mind let's go
i'm so bad i'm shaking so bad great work
guys i'm glad we all won together